I don't want to forge friendships with
homos know things lol some of these are
all real comments that we found on
YouTube or Twitter usually people are
behind screens but let's just bring them
to each other good time cool very
cathartic yeah here for it
Roman Rana says Christians are stupid
and they think they are better than
everyone else that's wrong I agree with
half of it Richard Hewitt our trans
people considered real people or are
they like imaginary friends you bring
out every time you want to make a
political point we're like a different
species of people this is from a German
gamma so basically the evangelicals are
like the Taliban of North America okay
yeah you can see why somebody would
leave that yeah all right the Duke says
the Jewish people a righteous people not
very good at sports
for the most part that's true this is
from at euthanasia
I believe in lesbians when they stopped
using strap-ons and dildos
I feel like I've heard that a lot every
person who hates on lesbians is like
well why do you feel like you need a
phallic symbol in your sexual life in
order to be happy I think I understand
what you're saying I didn't understand
what this person was referring to but
now I do
okay at William Elliot what an idiot
your sexual preference is a choice
whether it's to be straight or a homo no
one is born knowing anything about
sexual preference you have to learn how
to talk walk and even eat but somehow
you already know what you like sexually
the nerve of these Devils smth in wave
you have to be pretty dumb to believe in
God with so much evidence denying God an
absolutely zero solid proof to prove God
what [ __ ] thinks that someone was able
to bring every animal species on one
boat there's millions it was a really
big boat it's funny to the point where
it's like this is actually what people
say like online but it's like how else
are we gonna like really cope with it
other than just laugh about it you can't
stop them from saying what they're gonna
say I feel they tend to like generalize
things and it's easy to do that they
have no consequences I think if I were
to say something like this to you in
person there's a risk there's you could
catch me I just feel like they're
relevant enough to say something about
your life and it's not that way you
don't know people's stories we don't
know what they're going through they're
human being at the end of the day no
human being is ever deserves to be
treated that way if you're going to make
a comment about me or what I believe in
do so constructively I love a good tip
[Music]